all right moving on to food news pizza  hut heating things up they're rolling  out something called the new spicy  lovers pizza got marinara sauce but  there's also red chilies and crushed red  pepper on board  of course you can get it any way you  want it but they offer double pep  uh hawaiian chicken veggies it is only  for a limited time though  because heather's gonna eat them all  that sounds good  all right well let's move on down the  road to little caesars partnering with  the new film the batman it's a bad pizza  of course it's a new item called the  batman calzone  it's created by combining a pizza and a  calzone and this one is bat shaped you  saw it there it's available now at  little caesar's locations around the  country the batman is coming to theaters  march 4. the